in the opening scene we see a young
woman waking up in a mysterious white
Cube she has no idea where she is or how
she got there the first thing she does
is plead for help hoping that someone
will hear her however even after several
minutes of screaming no one comes
realizing that she is all alone the
woman decides to scan the place herself
she curiously places her hand on a wall
and to her surprise a door magically
opens the woman excitedly walks through
the door only to find herself in another
strange room which has reverse gravity
due to this she is instantly pulled up
seemingly to her death elsewhere we see
a man named Thomas McGuire who also
finds himself inside the cube he has a
suitcase with him which is apparently
locked by a code Thomas tries his best
to open it hoping that it can provide
him with Clues to escape however after a
bit of trying he gives up and begins
mumbling all of a sudden Thomas hears a
scream in the distance and realizes that
someone has been attacked losing all
hope of escaping alive he then begins
praying to God in the following scene we
see a beautiful woman named Kate inside
the cube while she is investigating the
place she notices a man on the ground
and rushes to check on him the man
abruptly stands up and attempts to
attack her but after a bit of
questioning he realizes that she's just
as clueless as he is the man then
introduces himself as Simon and they
start talking about their bizarre
situation soon after they notice another
guy named Max in another room he is
revealed to be a famous game developer
who knows a great deal about computers
while looking for him Kate comes upon a
blind girl named Sasha who is very
afraid suddenly another door opens and a
man in specs named Jerry enters labeling
the chamber as number four Jerry informs
Kate that he has been contemplating this
for six hours and has only visited three
rooms according to him these rooms are
moving yet no one within can feel that
how do you know Jerry moments later the
group is startled by a commotion in the
distance the blind girl Sasha says that
something is pursuing them and that they
must flee immediately however Jerry
opens a door and discovers Max trying to
help Thomas who has attempted to commit
the unthinkable fortunately before he
can pass away the group lowers him down
after checking his ID Max reveals that
he worked with Thomas two years ago as
they were both tasked with breaking the
Pentagon Mainframe a few seconds later
another door opens and an elderly woman
enters she appears confused and claims
to be looking for her gym she introduces
herself as Mrs Paley and it seems like
she suffers from short-term memory loss
following this the violent guy of the
group Simon tries to pressure Thomas
into providing information regarding the
cube however the latter is unable to
answer anything because of his critical
condition this causes a minor Ruckus
amongst the group but they are quickly
interrupted when the cube begins to move
enraged Simon asks Thomas once more
about what is going on and the old man
finally speaks up he says that they must
figure out a code to escape the
mysterious Place Max tries to open a
door but else as he feels a wiggle on
the wall then all of a sudden a wall
closes in and the room tilts to one side
they all pass through the door one by
one however when it comes to Thomas he
handcuffs himself and swallows the key
Kate and Simon watch in horror as Thomas
is smashed by the wall while his
suitcase is shredded to Pieces later the
guy inspects Jerry numbers each room
until they arrive at the 10th one in a
shocking turn of events he then informs
the group that he designed these door
panels and touch sensors that connect
one area to the next however he never
met the actual owners as he was simply
working as a freelancer hearing this
Kate and Simon become angry with him for
not addressing it earlier Jerry on the
other hand claims that he did not say it
before because he had signed a
confidentiality agreement he then states
that he had no idea what they were
working on but he had heard a rumor
about quantum teleportation speak
English Jerry you nerd just then Mrs
Paley notices an object and believes it
to be a tesseract upon looking close
closer Jerry confirms this and informs
the others that they are in a tesseract
or hypercube he says that a tesseract is
a four-dimensional equivalent of a cube
that represents a path through the
boundless Universe we know say the
others we've seen end game however he
also says that it is simply a
theoretical construct and is not meant
to be real meanwhile the group starts
noticing the number
60659 everywhere they go when Max opens
the door he notices a woman in a red
dress lying on the floor when he tries
to enter that room he is dragged
oppositely by reverse gravity and falls
on the floor after that the others also
follow him to that room the woman then
awakens and is surprised to Define
herself in such a weird place with
strange people she introduces herself as
Julia a big shot attorney following this
they each reveal their occupation and
their last memory before arriving here
Jerry confesses that he is a married
engineer whose last memory before waking
up here was going to bed Kate is a
psychotherapist who is on her way home
from the hospital when it's Simon's turn
he lies that he is a Management
Consultant when in fact he is a private
detective he claims that the last thing
he remembers was going out for drinks
Max then reveals that he is a computer
program designer and that he fell asleep
before waking up here Sasha claims that
she was completing her schoolwork as
usual in the kitchen Mrs Paley a retired
theoretical mathematician explains that
she was in the park looking for her dog
before arriving here at last the
attorney Julia reveals that she was at a
party the night before none of these
people have interesting stories moments
later the cube begins to move again and
a watch drops out of nowhere the strange
thing is that the watch is identical to
Jerry's and it even has his name
engraved on it later the group goes to
another room and discovers a dead man
named Dr rosenweg whose body is covered
in equations Max then explains the Dr
rosenvig was the top theoretical
physicist in the quantum chaos field
last year and was even nominated for the
Nobel Prize they see several
formulas scribbled on the room's walls
the group notices the number
60659 once again and this time Kate
writes it down on her hands meanwhile
Mrs Paley gets confused in her memory
and claims to be seeking her dog Ease on
izon is an international weapons
manufacturer where she used to work as a
mathematician the group realizes they
are somehow linked to izon because they
have all worked with or against him at
some point Mrs Paley then begins
babbling about how she doesn't care what
Alex trusk thinks and that she doesn't
want to be a part of this nonsense when
Jerry and Max hear this they're taken
aback because Alex Trask is a computer
Legend who is known around the world
they believe that this hypercube is
something that only Alex Trask could
create moments later Mrs Paley opens a
door and shockingly finds another
version of herself pleading for help but
before anyone can react Simon's
doppelganger finishes her off before
being killed by Crystal beams himself
witnessing this the group on the other
side is shaken to the core Jerry
believes it is a parallel universe while
Max and Julia believe it is just an
optical illusion in the next scene the
group continues to move from one room to
the next when Kade inquires about Alex
Trask Max reveals that he is the person
who programmed the virus that destroyed
the Tokyo Stock Exchange two years ago
as well as the one who broke into the
air traffic control system however Jerry
argues that there is no such person and
that it is all a hoax spread by
conspiracy theorists later when the
group is asleep Simon approaches Jerry
and confesses that he is not a
Management Consultant but a private
detective he claims that he was in
charge of finding or missing each on
employee named Becky she Simon believes
that this is the reason why he is locked
here just then Sasha who has a cute
hearing Hears A noise and awakens
everyone the group then observes a
hovering Square in the center of the
room it goes through several Tesseract
forms before becoming a lethal and
quickly spinning frame terrified the
group rushes to the other room but Jerry
does not make it on time he is drawn
into the tesseract act and dissolved by
the blades that shred him down to the
atomic level dork salad coming up
meanwhile Kate stays around to help the
blind girl Sasha who is still stuck in
the room they nearly escaped death by
gathering in one of the room's Corners
where the Tesseract cannot reach them
but after a while it shrinks in size and
attempts to track them down just when it
seems that the two ladies are going to
get killed Kate realizes that the
Tesseract only reacts to their movement
so she and Sasha remain motionless the
plan works and when the Tesseract
doesn't find anyone around it conforms
back to a cube and vanishes Sasha and
Keda relieved to have escaped death but
they are now separated from the rest of
the group elsewhere Simon starts to
suspect that Mrs Paley is an undercover
spy of izon therefore he ties her up and
begins terrorizing her but she appears
to have no understanding of what is
going on she constantly switches back
and forth between her memories and
begins talking about her dog and other
family members seeing this Max and Julia
believe she is innocent and try to stop
Simon but he threatens them as well with
his knife all of a sudden some Crystal
beams begin to grow from the wall Simon
quickly unties Mrs Paley to save her but
instead of running away she grabs onto
him the old woman says that she doesn't
care if she is dying she just wants to
take another life with her hearing this
a scared Simon finishes her off you
crazy old bat meanwhile Max and Julia
move from room to room in one of them
Max moves slower than time while Julia
moves too rapidly he then informs her
that these are variable time speed rooms
thank you genius Max later Simon
encounters Jerry from a parallel
Dimension surprisingly it turns out this
Jerry has just woken up and he has no
idea where he is at this point Simon has
become mad because of hunger so he kills
Jerry from the parallel universe and
takes his watch sometime later Simon
eventually comes across Becky whom he
was supposed to find he informs Becky
that her parents sent him to find her
and hearing this she becomes happy but a
short while later Simon loses control of
his sanity and kills her as well
elsewhere Max reveals to Julia that he
developed the computer game relativity
in which players compete in a 3D
environment while using several time
signatures he then says that a business
called cyber thrill had stolen his game
and he was planning to sue them upon
hearing this Julia urges him to give up
claiming that he can never win because
cyber Thrill is associated with izon
Julia claims to know everything about
izon because she is their attorney
realizing that they are going to die
soon the two then kiss each other and
decide to get intimate however they are
not aware that they are in a zero
gravity time dilated room as a result
they age quickly and pass away floating
in the air not a bad way to go though
meanwhile Kate has taken aback when she
discovers horrifying alternative
scenarios for her own death Sasha
informs her that time and space are
warped at their current location the
Tesseract will explode soon and reality
will crumble she then reveals herself to
be Alex trusk the hacker behind the
tesseract's development Alex admits that
when she found out ezan was actually
putting people within the tesser ACT she
tried to stop it they tried to hurt her
so she escaped into the only place they
wouldn't follow Kate is taken aback by
the Revelation but she still hopes there
is a way out just then an insane Simon
arrives in the room and threatens to
kill Alex so Kate stabs him in one eye
however he exits the room and quickly
reappears behind Alex aged and blind in
one eye Alex starts babbling that they
are all dead which causes Simon to lose
his cool and snap her neck killing her
instantly seeing this a distraught Kate
grabs a knife and finishes off Simon
brutally she then checks Jerry's various
watch duplicates and understands that
60659 is the time when the Tesseract
will explode oh yeah 606 o'clock
realizing that she doesn't have much
time left Kate snatches Alex's necklace
which contains a bunch of sensitive
information about ezan using this she
unlocks a panel at the bottom exposing a
dark hole Kate then waits for a few
seconds and jumps at exactly
606.59 right before the hypercube
explodes in the final scene she awakens
in the custody of ezan officials at an
unknown facility Kate gives them the
necklace but due to their
confidentiality she is immediately shot
dead the film concludes with an Ease on
official reporting that Phase 2 is
terminated as The Operators leave the
site
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching